when I was I bought us tickets for yeah
action movie hmm and I was looking for
it it was one of those movies where I
went you know you know how like
hereditary was the movie that for two
months I was waiting to see great this
other movie was one it was I love that's
not twice great so scared I've very
seldom seen a movie twice it's so scared
Last Temptation of Christ I love that
movie weirdly I think maybe nothing to
do and I was like 20 yeah yeah you that
movie really is when you watch it though
it is really emotional and the quietly
real music yeah yeah yeah everyone's got
wieners out the movie was that's why
dark night dark night the movie that
want to see Dark Knight Rises the second
one the movie that you're in I'm in the
third one you're in the third one that
one oh yeah dark it runs yeah yeah yeah
yeah but vain would be I would bang yeah
and I'm sitting there in the you you're
not in the second one
no I'm in the third you're the third one
yeah and I'm sitting there in the
theater and when you came on as the
doctor yeah the place went crazy
mm-hm when I turned around there because
I think it was partly because it was an
unexpected to see Thomas Lennon too much
tension there's a lot of tension going
in right there's a lot that you know
yeah yeah he scales to see murder yeah
he goes through the scale to see Gary
Oldman right who's maybe dying and maybe
dying right so when you turn around the
fact that I don't have like a bubblegum
cigar yeah or like a beanie before
Christopher Nolan memento right yeah
which is great seeing all one of the
best its mementos Greymon does a trip
yeah so when you're working with someone
because I've seen him over at the Oaks
you know gourmet gourmet with this kid
yeah I don't say anything because I just
get so intimidated but yeah um do you
I'm intimidated about him too yeah
that's what's actually a funny sweet car
that day when you were working or a
couple days whatever
90 minutes that 90 minutes that you were
working not only does he not slow down
on movies he actually dropped stays out
of the schedule because he starts to
speed up the more the faster he goes so
the more he makes a movie the less days
it takes which is
Reesie incredible but it's very true you
know he doesn't like have a trailer and
he doesn't like usually have monitors
he's just like on his feet making a
movie it's really impressive
because I have anything where he can see
something back maybe he does to my
knowledge I've just been around him and
he just like films it like a movie like
kind of like what Clint Eastwood also
does the same thing yeah it's just there
like he's there's a camera guy and I
mean I'm sure for the big stunts
sequences he looks at monitors and stuff
but for me you get with Christopher
Nolan you also get like two takes Wow
you know a third if you really [ __ ] up
the second one but probably not and now
knowing this
yeah is it first care are you nervous oh
my god I couldn't sleep for days but I
had I had one page of dialogue which is
all I say in Dark Knight Rises yeah and
it someone hand-delivered it to my house
like four months before shooting why he
was on red paper so you couldn't quite
you couldn't Xerox it right and
everything other than what I say was
redacted with a big black marker so I
didn't know who I was talking to well
except that I said well mr. Wain
yes I didn't say Oh mr. Wang there's no
way to know like I could be talking to
anybody
riah so what you're getting that
delivery that got handed over to a guy
handed it to me I was like magic I was
like this was really exciting I was like
message why need to like sign something
other guy looked him anyway no just like
if this page fell in the wrong hands
you're dead already
Wow yeah it was very exciting so but
imagine having you know it's like a
little paragraph in the Netanya little
burger and you have four months to think
about it so now your day off hello mr.
Wang where's the shot Chicago you ready
for this yeah this is one of those times
they're like hey Christopher Nolan would
like you to play this little part it's
basically a cameo in the Dark Knight
Rises the movie shooting in downtown Los
Angeles which is basically where I live
yeah you know not that fun I mean fun
obviously downtown Los Angeles
India
Pittsburgh and London and I was like my
[ __ ] I'm gonna get downtown right
right right I got London yes so you flew
to online you got to get a work permit
you got to go to a wardrobe fitting you
got to go back a hotel you got to eat
spaghetti but you know I love to do oh
you know I love you know so you're in
London right in a nice hotel crazy thing
I was in this hotel and then like a
fleet of women in burkas moved into the
second floor who were obviously with
some like Saudi prince or something yeah
yeah and they asked that I be removed
from the floor I literally came up one
night in my hotel lovely hotel yeah the
Langham in London and I have the worst
room and there's all these ladies with
like Louis Vuitton suitcases all the way
down the hall it's just steamer trunks
and just like burkas but with you know
like Jimmy Choos and like five $10,000
shoes uh-huh everybody looks at me
quietly and I'm like what just happened
some weird just happen I'm gonna go back
to my room and then later that night
there's a message from the manager who's
like mr. Lennon one of our guests needs
the whole second floor you I'm so sorry
yeah we have to move you to one of the
penthouse suites would that be okay yeah
I was like yeah that was gonna work and
then I did nothing in the movie right
could barely remember my lines cuz I've
known them for four months will you show
them though yeah now did you know
Christian Bale before that I did not so
you're in now where do you see him at
that in the makeup trailer or who I
don't yeah yeah yeah no the makeup
people hmm
I'm sure he's in some other and make a
bra situation so you're sad and he shows
up yeah and he comes in and the the
thing that's disconcerting is he's also
you know he's a big handsome guy yeah
yeah there's also like very mellow and
funny yeah like I can see that yeah you
also you know you forget you talks like
this yeah so like sometimes you'll see
me comes in and stop Batman
yeah and he's like oh hey you know
you're like oh yeah like oh you're just
like a kind of a sweet kind of yeah home
to Batman you know so when you can you
come in I'll be on Bruce and then you
you'll be my doctor yeah yeah but that's
so funny he's very unassuming and yeah
is a funny dude but how am I say this I
think maybe you weren't him and it
bought a person makes it easier though
that you were already in memento yeah I
don't do that I don't know if there's a
way to say that like hey Christian Bale
has gone know but not Christian but in
front of at least um know mr. Nolan
everybody I think I made a joke like
once every 13 years we'll make a movie
which is also what kind of sad yeah
he's the greatest he is one of the
greatest directors even Dunkirk was I've
seen it twice I love that movie
I just recently watched here's a crazy
thing about oh my god I just recently
watched Dark Knight holy crap I know the
middle one
yeah oh my god it's amazing I liked your
one too but uh yeah they're all great
but that second one and it's also begins
the gives us great - what's happening
yeah so so good and to see what happened
after that
with the [ __ ] Justice League what
[ __ ] happened I haven't seen it well
I'm gonna tell you what it is okay tell
me because actually don't know mmm I
loved wonderful that was great that was
the only one and I'm going to say this
okay is that Marvel has a franchise they
do light a lot of colors you know if
they're there now built like comedies
yes a lot of fun very funny jokes oh my
god Thor am a funny movie from the very
beginning when he's in the chains and
he's just like I'll be right back around
with you yeah yeah it's so funny
so as I'm you know I'm not a big comic
book I but I know I think they should
have used Christopher Nolan's movies as
a foundation
it said we're gonna play this [ __ ] real
yeah and gritty you know and we're gonna
since they're doing the funny we're
gonna do the real but they didn't do
that they made it very glossy you've
seen those movies yeah no there's like
there's a glow about things you know
your eyes funky either CGI looks weird
in there it's humorless lifeless and
I've never even sat through the whole
thing on these things [ __ ] things
I'll like leave or turn it off or
whatever they're [ __ ] garbage is
really funny and like in dark night yeah
the thing with the pencil that's all
that's how you meet him that's [ __ ] he
basically comes in he's like yeah yeah
that was crazy and if his death also God
rest his soul and rest in peace okay I
know what I'm doing this you were kind
of doing no because you're the baby I
have a pen yeah that wasn't doing
anything
no you're showing everyone yeah you like
it but uh it oh that also his death
makes he makes that movie also very
tough to get around it gives it an extra
level of like mystery all right right
yeah it'll never who's it like as a
Tibetan Montana you'll never get it
again in any way the way you're saying
[Music]